I heard Monday when I was about 11 kind
of just came down on the fastbreak made
the wrong turn and tore my ACL and my
MCL
and I was thinking wow that's not good
news for somebody so young he actually
been playing on the circuit for since he
was 11 years old with a torn ACL and
most people didn't know he was like that
they did surgery on the MCL and kind of
left ACL alone they didn't want to like
stunt my girlfriend thing like that
doctor says if he could physically play
on it then he's good to go
he said he can't do any more damage than
was already done there and then you know
over the years you've kind of forgot
about it I honestly forgot that I had
told me so
the doctor told me and my parents that
you know about his junior senior year
you know it'll probably have to have the
ACL surgery done so he sat on junior
year then the doctor felt like his
further career might be jeopardized if
we didn't get it done now so and they
told me that I pretty much didn't have
ACL they couldn't really see it the
doctors really complexed he looked at
and said they've never seen anything
like it
they've seen you know a CR not really
being in the knee but not athlete really
playing on their foot as long as I you
know played on mine after they told me
that you know I that's when I had to go
back and thank God for letting me play
the game I love to play you know even
after injury like that playing five
years with the ACL injury I think I
played on it for so long that I got
immune to to the feel of it
in the pain so I think it was just God's
blessing honestly you know I just thank
him for being able to get me through
that injury and bounce me back the way
he did and getting this great
opportunity to play at the McDonald's
all-american game
his biggest goal was to become a
McDonald's all-american and for him to
not claim a junior year to come back and
do everything that the doctors told him
to do rehabilitate and get yourself back
on the court he's done that plus more
and it just shows a lot about his
character type of person he is
the work I put in with stuff looking
forward to keep building up the knee and
everything around it I've still got a
little ways to go but it's definitely a
lot stronger than any other time that
I've really been playing I feel like
it's build me to Who I am today